[Music]
so can I ask you a hypothetical question
oh dear I don't like hypothetical
questions no I don't think you're gonna
like the real one either do you have the
papers yet
this is a devastating security breach
that was leaked out of the Pentagon the
most highly classified documents of the
war the time says 7,000 pages detailing
how the White House has been lying about
the Vietnam War for 30 years the way
they lied those days have to be over
okay people are concerned about having a
woman in charge of the paper that she
doesn't have the resolve to make the
tough choices Thank You Arthur for your
frankness let's do our jobs find those
pages we talking about exposing years of
government secrets is that legal
what is it you think we do here for a
living kid then I might have something
it must be precious cargo
it's just government secrets the New
York Times was barred publishing any
more classified documents dealing with
the Vietnam War
if you'd publish will be the Supreme
Court next week we could all go to
prison to make this decision to risk her
fortune and the company that's been her
entire life well I think that's brave if
the government wins the Washington Post
will cease to exist and if we don't hold
them accountable who will we can't hold
them accountable for don't have a
newspaper Nixon will muster the full
power of the presidency and if there's a
way to destroy you by God you'll find it
I'm asking your advice Bob not your
permission she can't do this the legacy
of the company is at stake
what will happen if we don't publish
we will lose the country will lose
what are you going to do mrs. Graham
[Music]
[Music]